on aperçoit François Bayrou qui sort de
la voiture officielle on se souvient de
sa prestation dans la gifle en 2002
alors voici le meilleur celui qui vise
le meilleur espoir Jordan
sans manche sous costard et à Marine Le
Pen sur le red carpet en 2017 elle avait
fait sensation et qu'ils sont là ils
sont partout dans les villes dans les
campagnes et voici l'interprète de
poudre de perlimpinpin et sa compagne
qu'on a souvent vu dans la presse people
qu'est-ce qui se passe les deux minutes
avant le direct c'est atroce moi je me
souviens parce que on évacue le plateau
cinq minutes avant le top départ et donc
là vous êtes tous les deux avec votre co
présentatrice et les deux protagonistes
en l'occurrence Emmanuel Macron Marine
Le Pen et même ce soir qui a 5 ans et là
silence de mort donc vous dites il faut
que je il faut que je casse le silence
je veux dire quelque chose donc vous
dites forcément quelque chose d'idiot
sur le plateau la température sera de 19
degrés les candidats seront à deux
mètres 50 l'un en face de l'autre leur
place a été tirée au sort contrairement
à 2017 Marine Le Pen sera à droite
Emmanuel Macron à gauche de l'écran à
côté 2 les arbitres du débat Gilles
Bouleau et Léa Salamé un homme une femme
pour respecter la parité je suis vais en
parallèle à notre événement qui se
déroulait en direct sur le plateau c'est
Patrick qui a englouti non
il y a le débat qui suit
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous pour ce
grand débat du second tour de l'élection
présidentielle moment très attendu de la
vie démocratique de notre pays bonsoir
Gilles bonsoir Léa bonsoir à tous
bonsoir Marine Le Pen bonsoir bonsoir
Emmanuel Macron bonsoir je vous rappelle
il y a 5 ans Tristan carnet avait dit on
a mis un décor couleur champagne c'est
ce qui se passe et donc moi j'ai dit je
me rappelle très bien j'ai l'homme le
plus idiot du monde à ce moment là je
l'ai dit email Macron et Marine Le Pen
vous aimez le décor couleur champagne et
là j'ai vu les deux me regarder ça sans
me répondre et rebaisser la tête j'ai
fait un flop
c'est fade assez triste c'est des
couleurs c'est moche
on y va Marine Le Pen c'est vous qui
avez été tiré au sort pour prendre la
parole en premier
[Musique]
c'est dans le monde mais le plus grand
atout de la France c'est son peuple
Marine Le Pen
oserais-je alors que le débat appelle
commencer vous interrompre
[Musique]
une prochaine émission pour le pour pas
avoir tout en même temps le drapeau la
musique allez en quoi seriez-vous une
meilleure présidence que votre
adversaire Emmanuel Macron je veux
démarrer avant même
vous pouvez reprendre
j'en étais à dire que le plus grand
atout de la France c'est son peuple
morte
[Rires]
si je fais 5 fois le tour de l'Hexagone
j'aurais littéralement parcouru combien
de côtés
[Musique]
Karine
non mais laissez la suivre sur les
autres mots alors pourquoi c'est quoi
donc vous faites 5 fois le tour de
l'Hexagone l'Hexagone un hexagone à
combien de côté 7 on a malgré tout
contrairement aux chiffres que vous
pouvez donner baisser le chômage il est
passé de 9,6 à 7,4% et le Bureau
international du travail comme son nom
l'indique et l'organisme qui fait
référence il vous plaît peut-être pas
mais personne ne compte les catégories B
et C du chômage puisque ce sont des
actifs partiels ils seront contents
ne faites pas ils seront contents
un hexagone à 6 côtés si vous en faites
5 fois le tour 5 fois 6 30 voilà c'était